oh mein gott sie hier
sie sind die babys hatte ich schon
gespielt aber auch die blogs geräusche
immerhin blieb skeptisch der macht
klopps geräusche wie der kontakt zu der
conti gelenke nicht richtig beginne zu
früh geboren wurde und das sind
einmalige trägt das ist halt wieder
alles schön gerade wird die beine
und warum ist die großen hier also ich
es so was wie mutter kind kuren im
mutterglück
die ältesten ja sowas braucht jetzt ist
jetzt ganz wichtig dass er jetzt mal die
unterschied es gibt hier zwei sachen
alpakas es gibt einmal die ruag alias
die haben so ein teddybär fell und es
gibt die so genannten jurys die haben so
rastalocken mäßig das ist das ist zb
hier merkt man so gehassten teil
und das ist ok und die kunde aus
verschiedenen medical von ihr ja aus die
herstellung aus berlin aber alles suhri
und das ist ein normaler kajak-einer
bekommen die irgendwo auf der welt ein
kommt heraus und und jede und jeder
alpaka frau die wirft einmal im jahr und
ist jetzt muss wieder raus
okay kein wort reden okay er ganze sind
das alles nur noch da also jetzt kein
wort reden mädels
was ich aber nicht sprechen
das ist aber nicht sprechen
schwierig sei
hass auf nicht weil die kakerlaken
er hat es besondere alpakas ist die die
pinkeln immer auf die tat machen wir
keine gleiche stelle wenn wir alt werden
die packers 820 18 bis 20 jahren
aber die wir jetzt nur also die wir
jetzt nicht für die gleiche gemacht nur
ist es nicht übers herz bringen und die
zuschauer ein was so aus spaß heraus
sowas vier stück holen
also wir haben auch wirklich vor uns ein
fahrgast holte vier stück und wir haben
auch schon platz dafür
und das heißt es nun neben dem mutter
kind auf zu gut hier und die anderen
ganz viel auf dem feld ist ja auch viel
zu klein für wer soviel alpakas
möglichkeit und die alpakas sind draußen
auf dem feld und das ist welche die
kleinen tiere und die mamas und alpakas
sind herdentiere und also man kann ich
es ein altmark gehalten sondern muss
mindestens drei halten weil das so
soziale tiere und wenn es nur 12 halten
willst müsst euch so vorstellen wir
werden leben lang alleine oder zu zweit
in euer leben lang nur ein partner und
das sind soziale tiere dass zumindest
drei halten muss
und umso mehr nach umso besser natürlich
aber die brauchen viel platz und dieser
platz ist wirklich nur für die aufzucht
also für die mama und die kinder bis sie
groß werden aber ich hab's gesehen ich
unglaublich also was für soziale tiere
sind und wir sind gerade in berlin hat
es noch keiner mitbekommen habe wenn ich
hab das auch meines tores auf instrument
schon gezeigt und wir wünschen uns die
richtige alpakas und die summe nach
hause nehmen und das rennen er hat recht
eine marzipan x factor hier in berlin
ist aber leidenschaftlicher etwa durch
das ist ja hier hat das gesagt sie hier
er ist ja ich zeige man den süßesten vor
allem das reich ist nicht der dass ich
verstand
und wie das hemd mal gesagt hat die
werden zwischen 18 und 20 jahre alt und
guck mal hier und die insbesondere
alpaka ist es ist einzigartig
die haben sonst hell und dieses in
münchen holt die haare sind roll
deswegen ist es aus diesem stoff und bat
bei alpakas im winter müsse ein parka
kleidung hatte es gibt nichts wirklich
nichts was wärme hält als ein verkauf
und die werden auch einmal im jahr
werden die geschworen
und es macht man meistens in einem
tierarzt man hier zum beispiel seht ihr
auch der wurde geschoren und zwar im
april schon und das alpaka hier das wenn
zwei gesagt das hat so klebebänder daran
sehen dass wir hier klar wir werden da
hier und hier
und es hat komisch beine gehabt und
damit die beine richtig wachsen
jetzt kommt schon zusammen
sich in die karten naja musst du
aufpassen so gut läuft
nein kommt nicht neben schafften sie
aber so man ein paar kam ihr nach hause
nehmen
dann passen wir auf das alpaka auf ok ja
sagt aus dass für ungefähr 130 alpakas
und 40 jahren noch neuseeland und die
werden auch mit der zeit dass die
geräusche und die scheinen alle an
ok
und informieren euch wenn man etwas
neues gibt alfa cars und weil die vier
stück daheim haben wir haben daraus ein
großes feld wo man sich drei laufen
lassen können hier also denn was gut
bis zum nächsten rat pack ab dem